hey everyone it's sarah thread sterner
sori and calm and today I want to
demonstrate how to check a blood
pressure manually first you'll need to
perform hand hygiene and gather your
supplies you'll need a stethoscope and a
manual blood pressure cuff so let's
measure a blood pressure manually to do
that we want to make sure a patient is
sitting down with their arm at heart
level and their legs are uncross now
they're lying in bed you would want to
make sure that this arm is at heart
level then what we're going to do is we
are going to get our stethoscope and our
blood pressure cuff and you want to make
sure you get the right size cuff for
your patients arm because if you use too
big of a cuff or too small of a company
can throw off the reading and what we're
gonna do is we're gonna palpate the
brachial artery because this is the
artery we're gonna be listening to to
get our blood pressure because we're
going to be getting our systolic number
which is that top number and this is the
first sound we hear and then our
diastolic number which is the bottom
number and this is the point where we no
longer hear the sound so whenever we're
looking at the gauge of our blood
pressure cuff we want to make sure we're
really noting those points because it's
gonna tell us our systolic and diastolic
number so what we're going to do is
we're going to put our cuff on our
patient and we want to make sure we find
the brachial artery this is the artery
we palpate that we'll be using to
determine our blood pressure and it's
found in the bend of the arm so we're
going to find it and it is located here
and we're going to look on our cuff and
our cuff has these arrows and because
this is the left arm we're going to make
sure that this arrow is pointing in that
direction of where that artery is so
you're gonna put the cuff up about two
inches above the bend of the arm first
what we want to do is we want to
estimate the systolic pressure so we
want to find that number to do that
we're going to palpate the brachial
artery and we're going to inflate the
cuff until I no longer feel the brachial
artery and
point when I no longer feel it I need to
make sure I'm looking at this gauge to
know that number because that number is
our estimated systolic pressure number
then when I go to take the blood
pressure I'm going to inflate the cuff
30 millimeters of mercury more than the
estimated number now the whole reason
for doing that is because we want to
avoid missing the auscultate gap that
can occur in some patients on all
patients have it but some it's usually
patients with hypertension because the
oskol Tauri gap is like this abnormal
silence that can occur and it will throw
off whenever you actually hear that
first sound which is your systolic
number so I'm inflating the cuff by
filling on the artery and I'm going to
note the point where I no longer feel
the artery which is about at the hundred
then I'm going to deflate it completely
and wait about thirty to sixty seconds
and then we'll take the blood pressure
so we're estimated systolic number is a
hundred now I'm going to inflate the
cuff to a hundred and thirty and that
will avoid missing the oscillatory gap
if one was present so I'm going to take
my stethoscope put it in my ears you can
use the bell or the diaphragm of your
stethoscope I like to use the Bell
because it's best at picking up low
pitched noises so we're going to place
that over the brachial artery do it
lightly don't fully compress it because
you can include the artery then we're
going to inflate our cuff to a hundred
and thirty millimeters of mercury and
we're going to let it fall about two
millimeters of mercury per second and
we're listening for that first
sandwiches our systolic number okay is
104 and we're listening for that last
sound and it was 78 so the blood
pressure is 104 over 78 then once you
have your reading make sure you fully
deflate the cuff full of air and you're
going to take the cuff off of your
patient of course and clean it
if it's not disposable and you will
document the blood pressure and what arm
you took it in now water normal blood
pressure readings according to the
American College of Cardiology 2017
updated guidelines a normal blood
pressure is a systolic less than 120 and
a diastolic less than 80 elevated blood
pressure would be considered a systolic
of 120 to 129 and a diastolic less than
80 hypertension stage one would be a
systolic of 130 to 139 or a diastolic 80
to 89 and hypertension stage 2 would be
a systolic greater than 140 and a
diastolic greater than 90 okay so that
is how to check a blood pressure
manually thank you so much for watching
and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for more videos